Brian went horseback here in the Honda
inside a report on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Brian
good god rich please give the update one
to the football training camp
the Broncos rookies and veterans report
Wednesday Brian both thank as soon as
soon as that happens they forget my name
well I don't know about that I mean
Korea is Chris Paul potentially on the
move after after that you think he's
just staying put in a coma city what do
you think no they're gonna try to trade
him for sure but I mean and I and I will
preface this by saying you know things
can change quickly but you know in
talking to some of the into parties I
don't think the Thunder are in any hurry
to trade him and it's a difficult
complex trade I do you know we know we
had the Kyrie Irving trade in that book
blasted so August we all remember well
some of us do the Dwight Mayer the
Dwight Howard saga that lasted into
August I don't know if there's going to
be as much intensity with this but rich
this is a strange situation Chris Paul
is a future hall-of-famer has been
pretty effective when he's been healthy
the last two years and as a president of
the Players Association very powerful
and influential guy and his contract is
still is regarded as one of the worst in
the league and to get rid of him
the the Rockets just you know sent two
first-round picks and to pick swaps
because of such a bad contract now the
Rockets wouldn't say that they'd argue
they were training for an all-star point
guard and also Westbrook and that's a
fair thing to say but if you go out
there and survey teams some teams would
say the only way I'm taking this Chris
Paul contract not necessarily player but
taking 125 million left is if you give
me Draft X yeah you don't just have to
give me the player you got to give me a
drastic cuz I got to swallow this salary
and I think the Thunder are saying well
if that's the way you feel we're in no
hurry and maybe you'll need Chris Paul
come October November December but Chris
Paul obviously he doesn't want to waste
time he's 34 going on 35 he wants to
play what the team is going to contend
and clearly that's not the Thunder so
this could get done in 24 hours this
could get done
in 24 days we get down 24 weeks I
honestly don't know Brian when worst
here on the Rich Eisen show so let's
let's talk about the genesis of the
Westbrook Chris Paul conversation when
did that happen the minute that Paul
George shocked everybody by getting the
exit visas to Oklahoma City what's the I
mean to Los Angeles what do you think
Brian well it wasn't the minute but that
day and I don't know if it was day or
night because I think James Harden was
in Asia somewhere from what I am told
James Harden got on the phone with
Russell Westbrook and they've known each
other since they were 10 years old they
you know they're both from LA they're
both in roughly the same age group they
they played together on Team USA in the
past they got on the phone with and of
course they were teammates and big on
the phone together and Russ was I think
ready to move on after that move and
James Harden was ready to move on from
Chris Paul I don't think it was a
situation where James Harden was saying
you've got to get Chris Paul out of here
but I do think that he made it clear to
management that if there was something
that they could do with Chris Paul that
he would support it and once Russell
West became available I think James
Harden did everything he possibly could
to make it known to his organization
that he wanted that to happen and that's
one of the reasons why they you know
sent out Chris Paul and the picks
because I think James Harden wanted it
to be so and so that means that James
Harden and Russell Westbrook have some
sort of agreement and have some sort of
understanding about playing together and
to me that's the most important thing
because they're gonna have to sacrifice
their games this is it'd be one thing if
if the team made the marriage and and
you know sit here now you got to adjust
and that's happened in the past we've
seen that happen a lot of times this was
the players creating the marriage and
the teams the team now has to figure out
how to make it work and this is the new
NBA so based on your knowledge or
thought process here it was harden who
would call up Daryl Morey and say hey I
just got off the phone with Westbrook
and he'd be willing to come here is that
and then more
goes and calls Presti and says let's
talk shop is that basically the way it
happened I wish I knew those exact
details rich I don't I just know that
they were in contact and I wish I could
tell you Oh James called rust or rust
call James I don't know who calls him I
don't know who texted whom whatsapp DM
you know Facebook message I don't know
how it all worked but I do know that
Ross and James were speaking about the
possibility and and you know rust went
to the Thunder and said hey can you send
me to Houston and James said hey can you
can you try to get Russell and that's
how the deal went down so I had David
Griffin of the pelicans front office
last Thursday Brian and I asked him
about why can't a general manager tell a
player no we're just not sending you
even if you've asked for a trade and his
response was it you know it's not that
simple because players know each other
for years and he called us a basketball
legal tampering Brian that's what he
called it here that he likes to call a
USA basketball legal tampering because
players get to know each other and they
all say that where they want to play
with each other does the NBA like what's
happened over the last couple weeks well
no I wish I listened to that
conversation because my guess is III
assume Chris wasn't complaining about it
because no no it was not it was Team USA
it was Team USA that helped LeBron and
Kevin Love get to know each other which
triggered LeBron getting Kevin Love to
want to be to play for the Cavs that
they played together on Team USA in
London 2012 in 2014 they were teammates
with the Cavs and David Griffin we the
first to tell you that you know that was
the genesis of that and if you go back
and look at team you know are the Rio be
a real Olympic team and he can start
figuring out the pairings that have
happened since then and you know this
isn't unheard of I mean there's a lot of
different ways this happened over the
years I mean players who have the same
agent who have tried to play together
for years and decades it's not new well
I think the NBA I think the frustration
amongst the teams is is that some of
these deals are prearranged than they're
not involved so let me give you the
classic
example of this offseason sir Al Horford
al the Celtics thought they were keeping
out Warford you know he was going to opt
out of this contract they knew that they
said okay we're going to negotiate a new
contract with you next thing you know Al
Horford says hey I'm going to go another
direction and it if itself experia
ranged deal lined up ready to go with
the 76ers now I don't know whether
that's true you know very few people are
going to know whether that's true but
that's what the Celtics I think believe
and so that's the kind of tampering that
drives teams crazy and you know the
thing is though the league has kind of
thrown their hands up
they've openly admitted that they can't
control player 2 player tampering they
can't stop James Harden from calling up
Chris Paul two years ago and saying hey
why don't you come play with me for the
Rockets go tell the Clippers you want to
be traded here they can't call Russell
Westbrook they can't stop they can't
police that and they've chosen not to
punish teams for doing you know
tampering or alleged tampering outside
the season so if you say something about
a player on the TV show in December
that'll get you find if your team season
is over and it's the Draft Combine and
your team meets with an agent and starts
making an offer to a free agent who
still six weeks away from free agency
the NBA has let that go and buy them
rich even by them letting the free
agency window to go from midnight to
6:00 p.m. which frankly is better for
fans and better for television partners
like us we have five hours show that
started at six o'clock Eastern when last
year our show started at midnight
Eastern and everybody was sleeping when
when Paul George decided to resign this
year everybody was wide awake but by
even doing that the league is sort of
giving a tip to the cap that they know
all these deals are going to be pre done
so they've kind of gone down the road
and I don't know if they can put the
toothpaste back in the tube well just to
let you know Griffin was not complaining
I asked him you know the basic question
is why is it difficult because I'm
coming from the world in the NFL where
for instance what's going on with Melvin
Gordon right now I'm sure the Chargers
are gonna try and work out a deal with
him but in terms of trading him I mean
maybe if the Packers
you know from their hometown and what's
Johnson blows them away with a deal
which doesn't usually happen in train
camp anyway the answer is gonna be no
then hold out Melvin well you know and
when you come back we'll be welcoming
you back and let's go in a Super Bowl
together the NBA just seems to be a
totally different story and Griffin was
his response was hey I just want to
create a spot where the stars want to
stay and if the stars do call up another
star they want to come to my spot that
was essentially what he was saying last
week and that's very pragmatic that's
very pragmatic because really what we're
we I guess if you're in a Hollywood okay
and you have a for movie deal with
paramount you know it's been a
long-standing thing you just go listen
paramount you and I are done we're I'm
getting out of this and and they say in
Hollywood that a deal is over when the
talent says it's over and that's kind of
where we are in the NBA James Harden and
Russell Westbrook have three and four
years left on their contracts this is a
situation where the teams would have all
the power
but those contracts don't mean anything
if you're a superstar now if you're you
know a player who averages 15 points off
the bench you don't going to have the
same sway but if you're a superstar your
contract length doesn't mean anything
and the difference between the NFL and
the NBA is there is not guaranteed you
know so Chris Paul may go downhill and
he may not be the same player in year
three of this contract that he was in
year one they a team that has him can't
cut him and not pay him the last eighty
million on his deal they have to pay and
so that's the big difference and the
reason that they have that leverage and
the reason that you can do is because
our old Swartz and ager can move product
and Chris Paul and James Harden and
Russell Westbrook and their past have
been able to move product and in the NBA
where it's a five team player game this
sounds very basic but I don't think it's
something she can't say in a five player
game when you have one player who's
greater than almost everybody else it
makes a lot bigger difference and
they're running back or a quarterback or
a left tackle and even a left fielder a
designated hitter and so the players
have figured this out it's taken them I
think the beginning of this was you know
Kareem abdul-jabbar demanding to be
traded only for the Lakers Oscar
Robertson filing a lawsuit that was the
foundation of free agency in the NBA
it's taken 40 some years but the players
finally
have gotten themselves into a position
where they're going to maximize their
power and I don't know where the owners
are going to go because while they can
sit there in their group and say we got
to stop this as soon as a superstar
player raised his hand is available on
the free agent market or or demands a
trade like Kawhi Leonard they beat each
other over the heads to get to get their
hands on the guy and I just think we
have that's the most powerful position
in all of American sport NBA superstar
and those guys are starting to leverage
it couple more minutes left with Brian
Wynn horst of ESPN in the Honda inside a
report last time you were on Kawhi was
making his decision who knew that at the
time he was making phone calls to people
like Paul George for sure to say come
join me and you said that Kawhi had in
his hand the future of the super team
era and that if he chose the Clippers or
he chose the the Raptors he would end it
and sure enough Brian we do not have a
team in the NBA going into next season
with three bonafide a list superstar
players on it like say obviously the
Warriors did who's the best two-man game
in the NBA going into next season based
on everything that we've seen and by the
way that was why the clip but the
Clippers had to pay five first-round
picks because they knew the Kawhi
Leonard could have walked to the Lakers
now we'll never know if he actually
would have done it right
but because the Lakers were there as the
option to become the next great super
team that maybe could have won three
titles in the next four or five years it
spooked the Clippers enough to give up
the picks to get Paul George that's what
I mean by him having the power in his
hand so you know I think what what's
really gonna be a factor now I think if
you looked at last year's Raptors team
they had one amazing player they had a
couple other star level players Kyle
Lowry and Pascoe siakam but the reason
that they were so incredible is their
overall depth they were flexible they
could play a whole bunch of different
ways and so when you look at what's also
now if you got up if you're looking all
these teams with multiple superstars who
has the depth who can play five or six
different ways who can survive an injury
to their starting center or their
starting you know point guard
the Clippers are right there you look at
them they are too deep throughout their
entire roster they had the best defense
for the Western Conference arguably last
year I think you look at the Utah Jazz
they're stars at the front end aren't
quite as good Mike Conley and Donovan
Mitchell are not LeBron and Anthony
Davis but they're they're too deep chart
is awesome the Denver Nuggets too deep
chart is awesome those three teams
really light up the board to me in the
West and then you have a team of LeBron
and Anthony Davis they're going to win a
lot of games and then in the East I
think the the Bucks are in great
position they did lose Malcolm Brogdon
but they were able to retain most of the
rest of their roster they're gonna be a
terrific two-deep team all the way
through their whole lineup to me they
are the favorite in the East when and
the last one for you you know so much
carving in the direction of the Lakers
from after magic did his made his first
take appearance and we talked about a
dumpster fire and El Segundo and what's
going on in the front office now all the
pieces have landed and I think this
roster is much better than the one that
they started last year with I'm
wondering what you and the rest of the
league are saying about the Lakers right
now that they are in going into year two
of LeBron with a bonafide
top-notch top a-list player and Anthony
Davis there and and the rest of the
roster around them the way it is yeah I
do I did a story on this last week I
talked to like 10 or 12 people in the
league to get their opinion on where the
Lakers are and number one they got
Anthony Davis as you said so they can't
say Davis they literally filled three
guys that look like me they're gonna be
better because they have to they have to
Hall of Famers on their roster okay so
that's obviously he's secondly with the
signings that they've made rich this
summer way better sit around LeBron last
year they were living under some dream
world and LeBron was gonna change the
way he played now they're like look
we're just gonna we're gonna let LeBron
play like he has for the last 16 years
which is he's going to control the ball
so let's get guys around him who can
shoot better and can defend so they get
Avery Bradley they get Danny Green boy
they'd love to have Andre Iguodala if he
can work out a buyer I don't know if
that could happen but that would be
amazing if they got him so they're
they're much better suited to surround
LeBron with talent and they obviously
have Anthony Davis
to me they won 37 games last year they
are absolutely a 50-win team this year
playoff team can contend for a top four
playoff seem the West most people I talk
to and I believe it's myself as well I
don't see them as a championship team
right now because I don't think they
have enough flexibility I also don't
think they have as good a shooters as
you're going to need they're better but
they're not great and I and in the other
thing is you're really relying on LeBron
and they SAT able to stay healthy if
either of them is significant time and I
know that LeBron has it this time a lot
in his career but he is coming off an
injury-plagued season it's going to be
difficult for them to maintain that high
standing so Anthony Davis said over the
weekend in this press conference I don't
disagree with this give us give us a
shot against any team in seven games
completely agree but I think with the
competitiveness of the West unless a
bunch of things fall into place I don't
see them as a champion 15 but I granted
I don't feel you know hugely strong
about them but there's also the palace
intrigue of the coaching staff and then
I'll add this is the last one because
you're the perfect person to ask Phil
handy of the assistant from the Raptors
as well as previously from the Cavs just
got hired to be on the bench with Vogel
and Jason Kidd and LeBron it's amazing
he did not tweet a damn thing about
Vogel or kid but he tweeted about pH his
guy with the emoji of thank you I mean
that what he tweeted that out
yesterday's what's the significance of
this hiring Bryan well still handy is
one of the most well respected
development coaches in the league by the
players I don't know if he's respected
by everybody else I mean he left
Cleveland with a little bit of acrimony
but it was the guy he was Kyrie Irving
his guy he kept Kyrie Irving on the
straight and narrow when he was in
Cleveland the fact if I was Brooklyn I
would have tried like hell to get him
but maybe they did I don't know so
here's the thing I just learned this
over the last 20 years LeBron in July is
very different to LeBron in January
LeBron in July sits on the couch with a
glass of wine talks to lost if he talks
so he wants to change them so this is
how this season's gonna be different the
broad in January win at all cost I don't
care what my previous plan is
he's been very supportive of frank vogel
he came to his press conference I don't
think that can be overstated he is spent
time throughout the summer in LA now
ground he's filming a movie here they
spent time in LA working with the young
players working at the facility
I assume building a relationship of
Frank Vogel he has been way more
invested with Frank Vogel than he has
other previous times he said first-year
coaches but the LeBron in January that I
know I know that when the the bleep goes
down he will grab a tape the people that
he trusts and knows and that is Jason
Kidd and and Phil handy this is what
happened with David Blatt in Cleveland
he didn't have a going in respect for
David Blatt although he does I think
more for Vogel and when source trouble
early on he gravitated to the guy that
he knew which is tyloo and as time went
by it was very clear that LeBron only
gravitated to Thailand so I don't know
what he's going to do but my concern for
Frank Vogel is that LeBron will be drawn
more to those other coaches and he has
previous relationships with he would
again Team USA rich he won a gold medal
with Jason Kidd in 2008 Jason Kidd was
the point guard on that redeem team so
something we're gonna be watching very
closely it's very it's a very difficult
for a set of circumstances for Frank
Vogel to inherit it's going to be a very
difficult thing for him to pull off to
be honest I knew that was a good
question to ask you sir you are the man
Brian win horse thanks again I will not
forget your name when training camps
open trust me on that okay I will be
calling you today we still do two hours
so two one-hour shows the Barry SPN on
free agency work
let's go okay man well look the Broncos
in full on Wednesday and on top of it
rookies and a whole bunch of places
including Arizona calamari reporting how
does that sound for you on Wednesday
that's going to work you're the man
Brian thanks for call thanks again for
everything you bye-bye thanks Ian that's
Brian when Horst for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app